[Music]
google compute engine enables you to
deploy updates to virtual machine
instances in managed instance groups
using two methods
namely
rolling update incrementally deploys
updates in all vms of the mig
canary deployment it is a deployment
strategy that releases an application or
service incrementally to a subset of
instances in mig
in a prior video we learned how to
perform rolling update to a mig in this
video we will learn how to do a cannery
update for migs here are a few benefits
of canary update it gives you the
flexibility to roll out new changes to a
subset of vms and assess impact and user
experience
can redeployments can be rolled back
quickly if something goes wrong during
an update then rolling back a subset of
vms is faster than rolling back all the
vms this can help minimize the
disruption to your end users it is less
expensive than rolling updates because
it uses less infrastructure there are
also some drawbacks to using canva
deployments they can be more time
consuming and error prone if they don't
use automation
implementation can be tricky for some
specific type of database applications
similar to rolling update a canary
deployment also support two type of
update modes automatic or proactive
opportunistic or selective
to learn more about this follow the link
given in the description
now let's look at how to perform can we
update in proactive mode in the google
cloud console go to compute engine
instance groups
in our project we have our instance
group can reupdate proactive mode this
mig has five instances
we have
two instance templates which we use to
create and update our migs
application current version the current
instance template and application new
version the new instance template that
we will update to select the mig that
you want to update in this example we
will select canary update proactive mode
choose update vms
under new template select the new
template to update to
we will select application new version
under target size enter the percentage
or fixed number of instances you want to
use to carry the new instance template
for this example we will specify one
instance this means that 20 percent of
the instances will be updated while the
other instances will remain on the
current version under update
configuration select the update type to
be automatic click on update vms to
start the canary update to monitor the
progress of the canary update open the
mig in a separate window
notice that only one instance is running
with the new version while the remaining
instance continued to run with the
current version
congratulations you just learned how to
perform canary update in proactive mode
if you need to do a quick rollback of
the canva update you can do so using
google cloud cli or the rest api
for canary update the best practice is
to fully roll back and update before you
try to update to another version let's
dive into a quick rollback demo using
the google cloud cli
run this command with the name of your
mig and the version you want to roll
back
in this command
canary update proactive mode is the name
of our mig
application new version is the name of
the configuration template we want to
roll back to
once the command completes let's go to
instance group page
congratulations you have successfully
rolled back the instances to its
previous version for more information
about cannery updates for mig check out
the documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]
you